NAME. WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE DRAWING
BECAUSE GEORGE FLOYD SHOULD
STILL BE ALIVE. BUT HERE WE
ARE EXACTLY ONE YEAR AFTER
THIS, FATHER, THIS BROTHER
WAS MURDERED BY A MINNEAPOLIS
SWORN TO PROTECT HIM THE
GEORGE, FLOYD MEMORIAL
FOUNDATION, HELD A
MINNEAPOLIS, FEATURING NT IN
SPEAKERS ART AND A MOMENT OF
SILENCE THAT LASTED NINE
MINUTES AND 29 SECONDS, HOW
THE CONVICTED POLICE, OFFICER,
KNELT ON GEORGE FLOYD'S NECK
AS FLOYD PLEADED FOR HIS
LIFE AND AGITATED ONLOOKERS
YELLED FOR THE OFFICER TO
STOP TODAY. FLOYD'S LOVED
ONES GATHERED IN WASHINGTON
AND AS WELL AS WITH SPEAKER,
NANCY PELOSI AND
CONGRESSWOMAN KAREN BASS.
THE JOYED. FLOYD THE GEORGE
FLOYD JUSTICE IN POLICING ACT,
WHICH JOE BIDEN HAD HOPED TO
HAVE ON HIS DEATH TO SIGN
TODAY.
BECAUSE JUST LIKE GMC.
AND SOME THINGS HAVE CHANGED
IN THE YEARS SINCE GEORGE
FLOYD'S MURDER THE MASSIVE
DEMANDED CHANGES IN POLICING
AND RACIAL INEQUALITY AND
AWAKENING ACROSS MULTIPLE
SECTORS OF OUR SOCIETY AND IN
LEAD TO ACTION, ACCORDING TO
BRENNAN CENTER, 30 STATES
ENACTED, POLICE REFORM
LEGISLATION IN THE YEAR SINCE
FLOYD'S DEATH. THOSE IN THE
DARK BLUE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED USE OF FORCE AND
OFFICERS DUTY TO STOP ANOTHER
OFFICER OR REPORTING
MISCONDUCT, CORPORATIONS
COMMITTED TO INCREASING
DIVERSITY AND FIGHTING RACISM,
AND AS ONE JOURNALIST TOLD
POLITICO MAGAZINE, THE PHRASE,
SYSTEMIC RACISM WENT FROM A
CONVERSATION, STOPPER TO A
MAINSTREAM CONVERSATION,
PRACTICALLY OVERNIGHT, BUT WE
SHOULDN'T
NOT EVEN NEED IT, GEORGE
FLOYD OR ANYONE TO DIE. FOR
ALL OF THAT TO HAPPEN. LET'S
BE CLEAR. HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN.
HE DIDN'T GIVE HIMSELF TO THE
CAUSE OF SOME HAVE SUGGESTED.
THANK YOU, GEORGE BOY. WE'RE
SACRIFICING YOUR LIFE FOR
JUSTICE. YOUR NAME WILL
ALWAYS BE SYNONYMOUS WITH
JUSTICE.
BUT HE WASN'T TRYING TO
SACRIFICE HIS LIFE. NOR
SHOULD HE HAVE HAD TO, IN
FACT, HE BEGGED FOR HIS LIFE,
CRIED OUT TO HIS MOTHER, WITH
HIS LAST BREATHS, MURDERED ON
CAMERA FOR THE WHOLE WORLD TO
SEE OUR COUNTRY. SADLY HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF WITNESSING.
SHARED ON POSTCARDS FROM E
MANY OF THOSE LYNCHINGS WERE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS. NOW, WE HAVE
CELL PHONES AND THE DEATHS OF
BLACK AMERICANS OFTEN AT THE
HANDS OF POLICE CAPTURED ON
NOT ONLY THE NATION BUT THE .
WORLD LOOK. I GET IT. WE WANT
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE. HE D AND
DESERVES OUR REMEMBRANCE,
BUT BLACK AMERICANS SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO DIE. AND THEN
HASHTAGS, EN MASSE TO ENACT
CHANGE, ESPECIALLY THE KIND
THAT'S LONG-LASTING. AND YES,
SYSTEMIC, TOO MANY SUCH
CHANGE REMAINS ELUSIVE.
DESPITE THE HISTORIC PROTEST,
THE MOVES BY LUKE LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO REFORM.
POLICE, DESPITE A PRESIDENT
WHO'S PUTTING RACIAL JUSTICE
AT THE FOREFRONT. WE ALSO
HAVE THIS NINE HUNDRED AND
KILLED BY POLICE IN THE PAST
YEAR, AND IT MAY COME AS NO
DISPROPORTIONATELY. BLACK.
CRISTO IS A CEO OF STUART
MILLER SIMMONS TRIAL
ATTORNEYS. WHERE JUSTIN
MILLER IS ALSO A PARTNER
TOGETHER. THEY SERVED AS
CO-LEAD COUNCIL TO GEORGE
FOUND FLOYD'S FAMILY DURING
THAT DIFFICULT HISTORIC
TRIAL OF FORMER POLICE
OFFICER DEREK.
WAS FOUND GUILTY OF MURDER
JOINING ME TONIGHT. CHRIS, OR
LET ME START WITH YOU. HOW IS
THE FAMILY DOING TODAY? ONE
YEAR AFTER THEY LOST GEORGE
FLOYD?
A LOT BETTER THAN THEY WERE A
YEAR AGO. TODAY WAS ACTUALLY
A DAY OF UPLIFT. THIS FAMILY
WAS INVOLVED IN MEETINGS FROM
THE PRESIDENT ON DOWN THE
SENATORS TO REPRESENTATIVES
ACTUALLY WANTED THEIR OWN.
THEY WANTED OUR INPUT.
THERE WAS ACCEPTANCE OF
BILL WILL HAPPEN. EN. THE
YES, AND I'LL COME BACK TO
THAT BILL IN A MOMENT, JUST
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE. HAVE A LISTEN TO WHAT
GEORGE FLOYD'S BROTHER. PHIL
WHAT HE SAID. AFTER THE N TO
MEETING, IF YOU CAN MAKE
FEDERAL LAWS TO PROTECT THE
BIRD, WHICH IS THE BALD EAGLE,
YOU CAN MAKE FEDERAL LAWS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SO JUSTIN, WHAT WAS THE
FAMILY'S MESSAGE TO THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT?
TODAY SPECIFICALLY
YEAH, I THINK THE FAMILY'S
MESSAGE WAS THAT CHANGE CAN
HAPPEN AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TO
READY TO GET SOME CLOSURE, S
BUT THAT CAN'T HAPPEN FOR
THEM BECAUSE THIS IS SO BIG
IN THIS CASE, REALLY
ENCOMPASSES THE WHOLE WORLD,
IT CAN'T HAPPEN FOR THEM
UNTIL THIS BILL IS PASSED. SO,
I THINK THE FAMILY IS GLAD
THAT PEOPLE ARE LISTENING ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, BUT
THEY'RE READY TO GET SOME
REAL HEALING AND TO TRY TO,
YOU KNOW, GET THIS PASSED.
AND MOVE FORWARD.
AND CHRIS, YOU ALSO SPOKE
AFTER THAT WHITE HOUSE
MEETING AND RECOUNTED A
RATHER TENDER MOMENT BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND GEORGE
PRESSURE ACTUALLY INTERACT
AN ABSOLUTE BALL AND THAT'S D
WHY THIS MAY BE A SAD DAY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, BUT THIS
WAS A SUPER HAPPY DAY SEEING
HER SMELL LIKE SHE'S STILL
SMILING. SO IF EVERYBODY CAN
JUST COME TOGETHER, DEMOCRAT,
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN AND
PASSED THE BILL. IF YOU CARE
ABOUT POLICING AND THE PEOPLE
IT WILL GET PASSED.
IN TERMS OF PASSING THE BILL.
AS YOU KNOW, CHRIS THE
PRESIDENT HOPE TO HAVE THE
GEORGE FLOYD JUSTICE AND
POLICING ACT ON HIS DESK TO
SIGN BY TODAY. THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE KILLING
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE BILL ARE
STILL ONGOING AND THE
PRESIDENT SAYS, HE DOESN'T
WANT A RUSH TO BILL. HE WANTS
THE RIGHT BILL. ARE YOU
CONFIDENT THAT LAWMAKERS ON
BOTH SIDES CAN COME TO A
SUBSTANTIVE DEAL ON THE
YOU KNOW, I KNOW HE SET A
DEADLINE THAT HE WANTED IT
TODAY, BUT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE UP AGAINST
A LOT OF UNIONS THERAPY. GETS
COME TO A DEAL TO COME TO
A DEAL TO COME TO SOME KIND
OF REFORM AND UNDERSTAND A
LINCHPIN MAY BE QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY. BUT YOU HAVE TO
ALSO LOOK AT ALL OF THE OTHER
STOP BLACK PEOPLE FROM BEING
KILLED. I UNDERSTAND,
IMMUNITY IS TO ALLOW A
LAWSUIT AFTER SO WE'VE BEEN
KILLED BUT WE WANT US TO NOT
EVEN HAVE TO GO TO THAT
POINT. WE WANT TO STOP
POLICING BAD.
LEASING SO PEOPLE AREN'T
DYING. SO LET'S GET THE BILL
PASSED. LET'S TWEET QUALIFIED
AND GET THE REFORM WE NEEDED.
PARTS WILL STOP US FROM EVER
NEEDING TO GET TO THAT.
AND CHRIS ONE OF THE BIG
STICKY BUNS. YOU MENTIONED
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY HOLDING
POLICE OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
IN CIVIL SUITS SENATOR. TIM
SCOTT, THE LEAD REPUBLICAN IN
THESE. NEGOTIATIONS IS
COMPROMISE, THAT WOULD ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SUE POLICE
DEPARTMENT RATHER THAN
OVER CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS,
DO YOU STAND ON THAT? AND
THERE ARE ASK, WHERE DOES THE
FLOYD FAMILY STAND ON THAT?
I GET IT. I UNDERSTAND IT
BECAUSE WHAT, YOU KNOW WHAT
THE COMPROMISES THAT PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND,
HOW DO YOU STYLE THAT
OFFICERS OR HOW DO YOU STAY
AT STOP? BAD BEHAVIOR?
DEPARTMENTS HAVE NO
INCENTIVE RIGHT NOW TO CHECK
THEIR OFFICERS OR STOP THEIR
BAD BEHAVIOR BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT LIABLE. THEY'RE NOT
RESPONSIBLE, THEY JUST FIRE
THE OFFICER, YOU CAN SUE THEM.
AND YOU CAN HAVE THE COP,
BUT NOW DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
ON THE LINE AND I GUARANTEE
YOU POLICE CHIEFS ARE NOT
GOING TO BEEP MAN, MESSING
ANYMORE WHEN THEIR DEPARTMENT
THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT. HMM.
JUSTIN. EXCUSE ME, I GOTTA
SEE MY THROAT. EXCUSE ME.
JUSTIN DEREK CHAUVIN WAS
CONVICTED OF FLOYD'S MURDER
LAST MONTH. THREE OTHER
OFFICERS. WHO DID NOT STOP HIM
OR AWAITING TRIAL THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START AUGUST. BUT
JUDGE DELAYED THAT TRIAL TO
NEXT YEAR, AFTER NEW FEDERAL
CHARGES WERE FILED AGAINST
ALL FOUR OFFICES. WHAT'S NEXT
IN THIS LEGAL BATTLE?
WELL, LIKE YOU SAID THOSE
THREE OFFICERS HAVE TO MAKE
A CHOICE. THE COUNTRY HAS
SPOKEN. MINNESOTA HAS SPOKEN
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE ND
ANY LONGER. SO THOSE THREE S,
CHOICE AS TO WHETHER THEY
WANT TO GO TO TRIAL AND AND
TRY THEIR LUCK OR IF THEY
WANT TO TAKE A PLEA. SO
THE NEXT STEP FOR US, FOR ALL
OF US WHO ARE NOT ON TRIAL IS
TO TRY TO GET THIS ACT.
PASTOR GEORGE. FLOYD JUSTICE
IN POLICING ACT PASSED
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO GO A
LONG WAY IN TO STOP.
FROM HAPPENING HAPPENING.
AGAIN, YOU SAID SOMETHING
EARLIER. THAT WAS REALLY
POIGNANT. YOU SAID GEORGE
FLOYD DID NOT GIVE HIS LIFE.
HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN. HE DID
NOT CHOOSE TO BE A MARTYR. HE
IS NOT JESUS CHRIST, GEORGE
FLOYD WAS KILLED AND
MURDERED AND WE HAVE TO STOP
THIS. AND THIS ACT IS GOING
TO GO A LONG WAY IN HELPING
TO STOP IT. IT WON'T BE THE
ONLY DETERRENT, BUT IT WILL
JUSTIN, AS YOU
SAID, HIS LIFE WAS TAKEN. IT
WAS TAKEN BY DEREK CHAUVIN.
ARE YOU EXPECTING IN TERMS OF
DEREK CHAUVIN SENTENCING NEXT
WELL, WE THINK THAT DEREK
SHOGUN IS GOING TO SEE A LOT
OF YEARS BEHIND BARS. YOU
CAN'T REALLY TALK ABOUT. YOU
KNOW, WHAT THE JUDGE IS GOING
TO DO. BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
WHAT THE JUDGE IS GOING TO DO,
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT WENT INTO THAT
CAME INTO PLAY DURING THE
TRIAL THAT WILL ELEVATE THE
I'M CHRIS AND JUSTIN. BOTH OF
YOU. ONE MORE QUESTION FOR
BOTH OF YOU. BEFORE WE GO,
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY BEEN CLOSELY
INVOLVED IN THIS CASE, AS
FOR THE FAMILY, BUT CAN I ASK
YOU BOTH? NOT US TO LAWYERS
BUT AS TWO BLACK MEN IN
FLOYD MEAN TO YOU? GEORGE
CHANGE. IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
GIANNA SAID WHEN SHE WAS ON
STEPHEN JACKSON, SHOULDERS.
MY DADDY CHANGE. THE WORLD.
BEEN DEALING WITH THESE CASES
FOREVER. I MEAN, ALL THE WAY
BACK TO WALTER, SCOTT WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD CHANGE THE
WORLD AND A LOT OF OTHER
CASES, THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY THAT CIVIL RIGHTS
IS BEING DISCUSSED. NOT JUST
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE OF OUR
WHITE, HISPANIC ASIAN
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD AND
CHANGE IS RIGHT ON THE
HORIZON, AND WE JUST GOT TO
THIS CASES, THAT'S WHAT
GEORGE FLOYD HAS STOOD FOR.
AND AND TO ME IT MEANS THAT
SOMEONE IS FINALLY. LISTENING
ARE FINALLY OPENING EARS ARE
FINALLY OPENING TO HEAR
WHAT'S GOING ON TO PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY. SOME PEOPLE ARE
IMMUNE TO THIS. SOME PEOPLE
DON'T SEE THIS, JUST BASED
PEOPLE. THEY KNOW. SO I THINK
THAT THE PANDEMIC PLUS GEORGE,
FLOYD ALLOWED, EVERYONE TO
KIND OF SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO US, THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS. AND AS BLACK MEN,
BAD PEOPLE'S EYES ARE OPENING.
WE HATED HAD TO BE JEWISH
LLOYD AND HIS FAMILY TO GO
GO THROUGH IT, BUT WE'RE
GLAD PEOPLE ARE NOW LISTENING
AND SEE HIM.
I MEAN YOU PUT YOUR FINGER ON
IT RIGHT THERE JUST IN IT.
IT'S HORRIBLE THAT IT HAD TO
BE GEORGE. FLOYD WHO WAS
KILLED. IT'S HORRIBLE THAT
HIS FAMILY HAD TO GO THROUGH
WHITE HOUSE AND CAPITOL HILL
TO MAKE THIS CASE. BUT IF
WE CAN PREVENT FUTURE,
GEORGE FLOYD'S, AS YOU SAY,
FORGET QUALIFIED IMMUNITY,
LET'S NOT HAVE THE KILLINGS
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
GENTLEMEN, CHRIS STEWART, AND
JUSTIN MILLER ATTORNEYS FOR
TONIGH